[Music]
for decades the prospect of
interplanetary travel has been
restricted by fuel but one organization
is working to use light from the Sun to
travel to the Stars 3 the Planetary
Society recently began the first orbital
test of their light sail two spacecraft
and it's already started sending back
images if solar sailing proves to be a
viable means of propulsion it could one
day be used to explore the galaxy to
learn more we brought in the planetary
society's CEO Bill Nye hi Bill
so congratulations on the successful
mission how's the light sailing going
sailing is going very well
so we have a small spacecraft that's in
orbit and it's getting a push from the
Sun every orbit this is very exciting
you know I was in a strong me class in
1977 and Carl Sagan was talking about a
solar sail mission how long ago is that
42 years ago and now we finally pulled
it off we are sailing on sunlight so can
you tell us a little about how the light
sail works I happen to have a model
right here so this is a 1/10 size of
light sail through so this is the 3 unit
CubeSat here in the middle and so it's
30 centimeters by 10 centimeters by 10
centimeters to give you a perspective
that's almost but not quite as big as a
conventional loaf of bread and then this
is 32 square meter sail so it's about
the size of a boxing ring and even if
you've never been to a boxing ring
you've seen one on the TV so the
sunlight hits these solar panels here on
the spacecraft by long tradition the
main part of a spacecraft is called the
bus the sails comes out of the bus out
of the main cube and they get to be
relatively this big and you can this is
the real material feel it Daniel it's
crazy thin isn't it
now get in from the edge we have
reinforced the edge to make it more
durable for carrying but so how then
that is it's like hardly let there yeah
much thinner than human hair and you can
see the rip stop feature in the sail
material so anyway sunlight hits it and
gives it a
it's just out of your everyday
experience that light can push something
and so we found that the sales do billow
a little bit just like sales on a
sailboat we found that because here on
these panels we have cameras two cameras
and they're gorgeous you see this shots
of the earth below with the sail in the
foreground and so it'll fly and we twist
90 degrees with every orbit because in
here is what nowadays people call
momentum wheel but you might have used
to you might used to have called it a
gyroscope a spinning wheel can produce
torque to twist the spacecraft in space
it's just amazing and this has been a
human dream so you could put this a
spacecraft like this and an orbit closer
to the Sun than the earth is now the
closer you are to the Sun the faster you
go around mercury goes around faster
than Venus which goes around faster than
the earth the earth goes around faster
than Mars and so on but what you can do
is be as close to the Sun as Venus but
because solar pressures hitting your
sail you could keep in line or keep
station with the earth and the practical
application for that is monitoring what
we call solar weather if there's a
coronal mast discharge of particles from
the Sun going at the earth you could get
five or six hours warning which could be
priceless in 2012 there was a soar a
coronal mass ejection of particles that
just missed the earth cross the Earth's
orbit about two weeks behind us as
Earthlings if that were to hit all our
communication satellites and
ground-based systems it would be a
catastrophic catastrophe the other thing
is that from that position in orbit
around the Sun you could watch for
asteroids as the saying goes looking for
an asteroid is like looking for a
charcoal briquette in the dark very
difficult to see at optical wavelengths
but in the infrared and just a little
above absolute zero and heat you can
find them and there are hundreds of
thousands
of asteroids that cross the Earth's
orbit some fraction of those would be
the end of the world so we want to find
those worth looking out for that's right
the preventable natural disaster very
low probability very high consequence
and so when this spacecraft is launched
it's about the size of a loaf of bread
right actually smaller than a loaf of
bread by a little bit and but it unfurls
to the size of a boxing ring right can
you kind of walk me through the process
of how that's done the standard has
emerged in spacecraft called CubeSat
cubical satellite and this happened
because universities wanted to build
these things the Air Force is involved
in this and so you can go online and buy
parts for cubicle satellites and the
standard is 10 centimeters by 10
centimeters by 10 centimeters XYZ a cube
well then the standards emerge so we
have a 10 centimeters by 10 centimeters
by 30 so it's what you call a 3 unit or
3u CubeSat and in there is a little
literally Swiss motor like a Swiss watch
this very very small motor on this crazy
small very precisely made gear train the
booms are very much like tape measures
they're thin steel ribbons and they wind
up into this very small volume they get
very almost flat and so we have a motor
that pushes them to get them started and
then it holds them back so that don't go
Zend out too fast and tear the sail and
this was something this is a classic
engineering problem you'd think you
might think if you wound up these
Springs they would just deploy just
unspool on their own but they don't
because the material is curved and when
you flatten it the curve changes and the
stress has changed we have software that
commands the motor to unspool the say to
deploy the booms then the sails are
attached to the end with those Springs
because the heating and cooling as you
go around the Sun
makes the booms change lengths a little
bit and so figured that out too and the
crazy thing is the sails are made of
this mylar material that's 20 microns
this is crazy and so you can pack this
huge shiny silver sail into these very
small volumes its origami so this is a
cube set and you've managed to raise the
orbit of this CubeSat is this looking to
the future is this something that could
ever be used to one day bring humans to
other planets or even other stars humans
almost certainly not the problem with
humans is they're heavy and we are not
electronic
we need to drink and recover the water
that we get rid of and it's very very
it's a massive system to support a human
but going to another star system a solar
sail is really the only technology
anybody can think of right now that
would enable that and what you would do
you'd build something like light sail
too and you'd put it in orbit and then
you'd hit it or push it with laser beams
then you would create laser beams here
on earth with an enormous amount of
electricity and shoot them at the
spacecraft and push it to another star
system and keep in mind if you were to
do that even a spacecraft the size of a
postage stamp would show up in the
Proxima Centuri Alpha Centauri solar
system for light-years away it would
show up there with the energy comparable
to a small nuclear weapon like a
Hiroshima's style bomb and so if it were
to hit something
okay we're from Earth cool this bullet
that's enough to destroy it
it's a great way to say hello in a city
yeah so I'm not saying that would it's
just don't get carried away everybody
it's like not a solved problem the other
thing that everybody's really enchanted
about is exploring nearby space and by
nearby we mean the Kuiper belt you know
where all these icy objects are orbiting
with a solar sail that got out there
because it could get up to 100
kilometres a second so what you would do
is have a solar sail that might have the
same shape as light sail to but the
materials it would be made of would be
able to hold their shape their integrity
close to the Sun so you'd send the
spacecraft in near the Sun and the you'd
have so many photons hitting it so
strongly that they would push it out at
a hundred kilometres and you can get out
to way out in the solar system
relatively fast that technology doesn't
exist right now the materials don't
exist right now but the longest journey
starts with but a single step so we like
to think of light sail 1 & 2 as part of
the overall mission of advancing space
science and exploration that's what we
do at the Planetary Society citizen
funded flight byte light well
congratulations on taking that first
step and thanks so much for joining us
bill Hugh Daniel